these are tuna cats though they're
better known by their very adorable name
sea squirts they get their name because
they can squirt water out of their
bodies when something touches them or
when they're taken out of water this is
the end of one of those tubes which are
called siphons coming off the sea squirt
and inside are several algae living in
symbiosis with their sea squirt home the
sea squirt has two siphons for a very
simple reason one is to take things in
and one is to take things out one siphon
draws water into the sea squirt allowing
it to pass through the organism so that
it can eat the little bits of Plankton
and other food traveling on that
internal wave and then once the c-square
is done with the water it passes it back
out through the other siphon
[Music]